I've pneumonia in both lungs you know
fine I mean my favor
Karen Mannering spent a week in hospital
in Margate being treated for Kovac 19
the mother of three and almost seven
months pregnant she's now recovering at
home her doctors say she shouldn't leave
the house until she's had the baby
good advice as there is uncertainty over
whether or not those who have recovered
from the virus can catch it again if
anything I still feel like a sitting
duck because if I get it again
especially this soon I don't believe I
could fight a second time
you know what I mean especially carrying
their baby now he's a lot bigger it's
been widely assumed that if you've had
corona virus your body will develop
immunity but the World Health
Organization now says that may not be
true there's been an expectation
maybe that herd immunity may have been
achieved and that the majority of people
in society may already have developed
antibodies I think the general evidence
is pointing against that for those
who've had the virus the temptation to
purchase an antibody or serological
testing kit is high antibodies are
little bits of y-shaped protein that
help fight infections when we get one
our immune system produces them to help
us get over it once produced the
antibody attaches itself to the anti
gene of the virus and destroys it
helping us defeat the infection once the
virus has been destroyed the antibodies
stay in your system for a time this is
what the blood test looks for but for
new viruses like kovat 19 doctors simply
don't know how long these antibodies
will last or if they're powerful enough
to guard us from future infection we can
use a lot of work of what we know about
viruses like SARS in years gone by
whereby immunity peaked at two or two or
three months and lasted for around three
to four years but of course this
scientific knowledgeable will continue
to grow the government's are advising
people not to buy private tests until
the reliable approved one could be found
and mass-produced so for Karen the
uncertainty and the worry goes on
literally I do not leave the house but
what I do not call it my little worm
safety pack so I have my face mask loves
I have an auntie back hand one but wash
then I have my dental spray for the
bottom of my shoes I thumb actually over
the top probably more so than most
people because I've been there I've done
it and I do not wish upon anyone the
government to will be concerned as
antibody tests were seen as playing a
key role in their lockdown exit strategy
Frasor Maud Sky News